sébastien michaud est entrepreneur
général en construction ces dernières
semaines n'ont pas été de tout repos
il a dû renoncer à 4 contre 1 les
projets des patios de celle qu'on avait
on dit
remis au printemps prochain le bois
traité et le bois d'oeuvre sont devenus
très rares et il n'est pas le seul à le
constater
marc andré roy terminent la construction
d'une vingtaine de maisons de ville
saint-laurent en 28 ans de carrière il
n'a jamais vu une augmentation aussi
rapide des prix du bois d'oeuvre
c'est une perte de profits pour son
entreprise ces maisons ont déjà été
vendus il ya plusieurs mois pour une
maison de ville c'est vingt mille
dollars de coûts additionnels avec
également des délais on est rendus
chanceux d'avoir les méthodes de 2 par 4
2 2 par 6 me plaît web via ne put 87%
des entreprises de construction
éprouvent des problèmes
d'approvisionnement de matériaux depuis
le début de la pandémie et le
confinement a aussi entraîné une ruée
vers les projets de construction et de
rénovation chez lanvin forêt on répond
tout juste à la demande
surtout cette année on a vu venir en
augmentation ces lotos constructeur dans
le particulier qui a décidé lui même de
construire son patio même si les
scieries roule à plein régime
elle rattrape difficilement le retard
suite à leur arrêt au printemps dernier
d'un phénomène extrêmement rare des
pénuries comme celle qu'on vit sont
vraiment associé à une crise sanitaire
bien particulière à des conditions
particulières la bigne dubois entraîne
une pression supplémentaire sur
l'industrie beaucoup d'entrepreneurs en
ce moment qu'ils sont en train de mettre
la [ __ ] douce de t'arrêter certains
chantiers puis de voir comment vois tu
l'évolution de ses couleurs
entrepreneurs et propriétaires devront
faire une révision à la hausse de leur
budget je suis maghrébine rochon grade
au canada montréal